he says he's at a hundred million plus
run rate the Twitter weight loss thing
we show that that's pretty interesting
did you sign up for it I signed up I
just ate a big old plate of veggies just
now because now cuz I'm like oh
this is starting so explain what this is
okay so when you're on camera you
predict this happens a lot but you get
self-conscious but also we are both
trying to lose weight our friend Justin
is doing a thing where we have then what
you do venom venom owe him money so he
tweeted out hey I got an experiment for
weight loss 30 days if you want in let
me know and you had to venmo him 800
bucks I did know just did it right away
just a pop mcpot commit myself into it
and then he's gonna send us a blood
glucose monitor it's a thin you for 28
days 20 days and basically the way it
works is he's gonna send a nutrition
plan and like an eating plan but if you
and if you stick to it you'll be fine
but well problem is most people don't
stick to it so here's how it's gonna
work
if your blood glucose levels go out of
the range like the healthy range the
weight loss range that he's gonna
prescribe for us so first it's gonna
monitor your baseline then he's gonna
say okay cool here's the range I want
you to stay in if you stay in that range
for the day he then knows you back 25
bucks for the day and if you don't he
keeps your money I love it
and he is doing this in a way where he's
buying all of our monitors yes which
typically cause I think $300 400 bucks
if we stick to it by the end of this
challenge we've paid $100 we've lost a
bunch of weight and we got paid back all
our money if you stick to it if you
don't do it so we're giving it's a
hundred bucks now I met if you if you if
you do it to the letter of the law you
get this four hundred hour device for a
hundred dollars and you lost your weight
I love it sick deal and we should
explain who he is he's the founder of
this thing called kettle and fire he
also I think is one of the founders of
perfect Heat oh yeah so to keto products
basically yeah and I have no idea but I
imagine his businesses collectively are
in the 50 or 60 million dollar in
revenue range so like he sees a lot of
he says he's at a hundred million plus
run rate for his to product for kettle
and fire and
where did he say that on his website oh
good for him yeah um I didn't know that
which is very crazy for a keto product
yeah so it sounds like he's thinking of
a new business
yeah go ahead and copy that yeah so I
like it so what we'll do is when we get
the device we'll just shout out our
blood glucose during the ship oh I'm
doing it I also use my body tutor where
I take pictures of everything that eat
right and I send it to my so I ate that
doughnut just now I'm gonna have to send
that to them and they're gonna shave me
you said that you ate it
well there's more out there I'll take a
picture of it okay but all I've eaten
today is a doughnut in an orange I'm
good all right cool cool weight-loss
idea I like it Justin Myers good stuff
[Music]